Orel Hershiser the World Series champ
Dodger broadcaster joining us on the
program are you able to exhale after
yesterday's game aural 6 3 to 15 yes I
do yes I did the only reason I didn't do
it last time is they didn't have my
coffee yet oh okay I had my car you're
fired up now let me start with a
velocity of you know the Brewers move
with Miley to start the game
how surprising was that to you I don't
think it surprised a lot of people I
think it surprised a lot of people how
quick it was first time ever on three
days rest we've seen them use openers
before we saw this done with Oakland I
think we're moving I think we're into
the future now I think people have
strategized this and it's been in the
back rooms it's been in the front
office's of people kind of playing with
the idea we've seen it to be you know
five men rotation six men rotation I
think we're going to be to a point where
there's pitching staffs someday and not
starters and relievers and culturally
things are changing and I think it's
going to change with middle market maybe
even low market teams that can't afford
that frontline starter or three of them
that you need to win a championship and
they're looking for a new way to compete
and maybe not more than compete maybe
win and it's it's a really interesting
scenario and a culture shift now you
make the move I had no problem with it I
understood what he was doing
took you know took some explaining in
the beginning where I didn't I didn't
know if Miley was hurt or not and then
we realized that it was just hey we're
gonna bring in a right-hander for a
right-handed heavy lineup but you know
your margin of error is so small because
if Kershaw is on then whoever comes in
has got to be great and you know they
roll the dice on it and Kershaw was
great yeah it was great it's gonna be
really hard even for another starting
pitcher to beat him right yeah so it's
it's just this new strategy to say this
is what our ability levels are and we're
going to attack it this way this is what
our roster says we should do to win the
game I I don't have a problem with it at
all and you know what
everybody's like well okay now this is
gonna upset Miley or this Miley knew
what was going on and Miley knew when to
throw they told them this coming out of
the last start I'm sure and when you
know as an athlete that this is my new
game plan you adjust your cardio you
adjust your weightlifting you adjust
your throwing on the side you adjust
your playing catch so this was used at
his side work anytime I was asked or
thought there's a possibility to go on
three days rest back in the day I didn't
throw my side work I just played catch
and you have to have confidence that
throwing the baseball is something that
you know how to do and rest is more
important so you don't go down to this
and have a side work and have this great
side work and your curve balls work
great your sinkers work great your
locating oh you're having so much fun
and you throw those extra 30 pitches
down there because it's just fun to play
baseball and fun to throw and fun to
know you got great stuff no you throw a
few you go oh mom feels great I'm
hitting my spot on three pitches I don't
need anymore I'm done it's like going to
shoot free throws and knowing I don't
want to go back to the three-point line
and make three-pointers now I've got my
stroke and I know I can make
three-pointers on the game day so I'm
fine rest is more important we're not
golfers we can't hit a thousand shots we
can't he'll hit chip shots forever we
can't go putt forever
we've got about 80 throws in our body a
day to be able to maybe pitch the next
day just to play some catch and that's
you just make an adjustment also with
Kershaw and I didn't have that fastball
he hasn't had that I don't know if he
gets it back until next season but right
you know as I told people when I was
growing up following baseball loving
baseball you know pitchers pitched and
and people look at you now like what are
you talking about Hershiser pitched he
didn't throw a lot of guys throw now I
mean Kershaw what we saw was I mean that
was brilliant to see that he didn't have
great stuff or he didn't have a
consistent stuff but he had it when he
needed to you as a you know former
pitcher at a high level obviously what
did you make of Kershaw is performance
well pitching is about location we've
seen balls thrown at 70 miles an hour
and 100 miles an hour and we seen guys
just get lit up you know and they come
back and they go I just didn't hit my
spots I didn't have my stuff well stuff
includes location I've never heard
anybody say I was hitting my spots
exactly and got bombed I've heard plenty
of guys say I had great stuff today but
got hit around or got bombed well that
tells you location is most important the
next most important thing in pitching is
movement late movement because the
hitter can adjust why does it
knuckleball work at 60 miles an hour
because it moves late and you don't know
where it's going to be so it's location
and movement velocity is the last
quotient we see guys yet yet at a
hundred miles an hour max month you got
a base hit to the opposite field on on a
97 mile hour fastball earlier this year
we had somebody hit a hundred and three
mile an hour fastball for a base hit
it's about is the pitch in the right
spot it gives you the highest odds to
get a guy out hit it have it hit weakly
or miss it and it you know is the pitch
have late movement and that gets it off
the barrel the bat gets it either swing
and miss or hit weakly this the love for
velocity is is part of the game that's
right now but I think the guys that are
winning they're still hitting their
spots even though they throw it hard and
the guys that hit throw below-average
fast balls which Clayton's fastball now
is below big league average big league
average fastball it's 90 to 93 miles an
hour and he averages about 90 91 talking
Orel Hershiser the former Dodger great
no Dodger broadcaster let's go back a
couple of days ago you were critical of
Manny Machado the played first base also
he said that he's not Johnny hustle
that's not his cup of tea here yeah what
bothered you more the play at first base
or he says that he doesn't you know he's
not Johnny hustle it's not his cup of
tea I absolutely love his ability and I
think that's why the bar is raised so
high for him because there's so much
ability in his body and you get to see
that all the time and sometimes you wish
you saw it a little bit more you
probably get to see it about 95% of the
time and there's 5% of it you go
man wish you would have ran that one out
or oh man I wish he attack that a little
bit more but absolutely I'm amazed by
his ability and we should be talking
about that the beauty of the game but
there are a few times that you know
people pay to see great athletes and
great athletes need to actually show
that and to hustle and you know if this
was on the opposite side of the field I
think people would be more critical that
we're a Dodger uniform and that are part
of the Dodger organization and part of
baseball I think you see a true critique
of what players are doing from the
opposite side usually and from the rest
of the game and the rest of the game has
been disappointed in his quotes and his
effort and disappointed in a few things
that he's done on the field so just
something you can't ignore no matter
what uniform you wear or what
organization you're with and I
absolutely love Manny and his abilities
and I have talked to him to his face and
said you know what a little bit more
effort all the time would be great what
are you saying
it's just his style the same thing he
says publicly he says privately his
style I you know what and and in some
ways as an athlete who is performed
there is a mindset that you find where
you perform at your best and if low key
if him engaging on a mental level of you
know last I you know fight or flight
syndrome where you're just I'm in fight
mode I'm not gonna fly but he's found
out you know I don't want to fly away
from this challenge I want to you know
fight it but when I fight it I'm not
good I tried too hard so maybe he has
found a place where being low-key he
finds he is at his best and it doesn't
always play well for everybody for fans
and maybe even for management or for
broadcasters but it plays well and he
understands himself and and that's where
I have to almost default to now well as
long as the front office and Dave
Roberts is fine with it because if
you're gonna pony up 300 million dollars
for Manny Machado then you know what
you're getting right exactly exactly you
know and I you know this is
oh it's just it's a hard topic it's a
really hard topic because we work so
hard to get to this place and and most
people that do have to use every ounce
of their ability to get to the pinnacle
and when you see somebody who seems to
have even more ability than almost
anybody on the field and and it's a kind
of a suave kind of approach it it's hard
but you know what it's it's not jealousy
it's it's not jealousy for his ability
it's boy is there more you just almost
crave for more the Dodger you want at
the plate with the game on the line is
who oh my gosh Kirk Gibson well no I
mean current current current Dodger
current okay I didn't know I knew we
Reese Jackie Robinson yeah the current
Dodger at the plate when the game is on
the line Wow
to me it's a joiner well Justin Turner
yeah okay yeah yeah it is best two
strike hitter in the game 50% of the
apat and baseball end up at two strikes
average for a two strike hitter and in
the big leagues below 200 he almost hit
300 this year with as a two strike
hitter your offense is going to function
if you can hit have a lineup hit above
200 with two strikes yeah he's
ridiculous the pulse is ridiculous the
ability is ridiculous the track record
of how he got to the big leagues and
became a star is ridiculous so you know
that he understands how to be a great
player and a good player and to function
hurt I mean this guy's been through
injury after injury this year and
playing with sometimes one thumb or one
one wrist or one you know a hamstring
and he still figures it out that's a guy
who actually understands the game and
applies his ability to it to figure out
the best way to succeed we're all good
to catch up with you again thank you for
your time we appreciate it
BP I'm sorry I was a little late I
thought it was in 8:40 it
wasn't in my time it was an 825 and I
was sitting there having coffee getting
wound up for you and remembering trying
to remember at sixty years old my high
voice thank you yep the former Dodger
great Dodger broadcaster Orel Hershiser
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]